e che emozione essere con voi questa
notte per accompagnarvi negli ultimi
attimi di questo 2023 ci divertiremo
balleremo voi mangerete Mannaggia a voi
maestro se qualche volta ho creduto che
fosse
impossibile E allora dalla regia mi
dicono che c'è da spostare
immediatamente una macchina una Fiat
Panda targata K 398 FP un pezzo che
dedico a tutti coloro che nel 2023 hanno
avuto problemi di cuore maestro Bat Go
Hey Walk out Doors Su dai che state
ancora digerendo il secondo canterò un
pezzo per ricordare quelli che sono
stati i migliori anni della nostra vita
inimi forte nessuna notte è
infinita anni della
nostra
v vi ricordo che a partire dalla
mezzanotte eranno servite lenticchie
cotechino Come da tradizione 5 4 3 2
2024 a tutti
arako fuggire S